good afternoon
we see now that since almost three
months russia is waging a brutal war
against ukraine
and it threatens all those that support
ukraine in its legitimate
defense against this aggressor
putin's war poses fundamental challenges
to our union and thus today
we had a huge package in the college of
commissioner that was dealing with the
topics
that emerged because of this war
for example today it was on this energy
security of supply it was a big file on
defense and we were dealing with a big
file on the support for our neighbor
ukraine and this i want to report here
first
on the energy topic
putin's war is as we all see heavily
disrupting the global energy market
it shows on one hand how dependent we
are on imported fossil fuels
but it also shows how vulnerable we are
on relying on russia
for importing our fossil fuels and
therefore we must now reduce
our
as soon as possible our dependency on
russian fossil fuels
i'm deeply convinced we can
and thus today we presented our plan
to realize these objectives the plan
that we call re-power eu
if you look at what has been done
already this shows that is a process
going on we have phased out of coal
or if you look at the gas
last year 40 of the imported gas was
imported from russia to the european
union
this year already in april we were down
to 26
so it's going in the right direction but
we have to accelerate
and with repower eu we show that we can
replace russian fossil fuels by working
on three levels
the first level is on the demand side
that is saving energy sounds simple is
simple but very effective
then on the supply side it's of course
diversifying away from russia for fossil
fuels
and towards other reliable trustworthy
suppliers
and the most important part
accelerating the clean energy transition
so massive investment in renewable
energy
fortunately
we do have already the foundation for
doing this in place
because we have as you know already
embarked on a transformation of our
energy system
to become climate neutral this is the
famous european green deal
and this european green deal and fit455
was already ambitious
but today we're taking our ambition yet
to another level to make sure that we
become independent of russian fossil
fuels as quickly as possible
this whole
approach is repower eu
so repower eu will help us to save more
energy
to accelerate the phasing out of fossil
fuel
and most importantly to kick-start
investments on a new scale
so i would say this will be the speed
charging of our european green deal
to start with the most obvious that is
energy saving
energy savings are the quickest and the
cheapest way
to address the current energy crisis
we will therefore increase the eu energy
efficiency target for 2030 from nine
percent
to 13 percent
then there is the massive investment in
renewable energy the biggest task
here we are increasing our target for
2030 from 40
renewable energy to 45 renewable energy
and in repair eu we come with a whole
host of actions
to scale up and speed up the clean
energy transition
i want to give you a few examples we are
for example proposing to speed up the
permitting procedures for renewables
as you might know today it can last six
to
nine years to have the permitting
process ready for a wind park for
example we now want to define go-to
areas and make sure that there the
permitting process is down to one year
the same goes for the permitting process
for associated infrastructure like grits
or another example
we're proposing a solar rooftop
obligation
for commercial and public buildings as
of 2025
and for new residential buildings as of
2029
i know this is ambitious
but it is realistic we can do it
now the third part
is
the look at diversifying a way to other
suppliers and here we know that when
europe acts together
it has more clout and therefore the 27
leaders agreed to set up a platform
for the joint purchase as you know for
gas for lng and for hydrogen
and as part of our re-power eu plan we
now propose an operational way forward
so with a joint procurement mechanism
and with a joint outreach to supplying
countries
this way
we can secure the energy imports we need
without the competition competition
between our member states that is
something we do not need
now all of this what i just described
will of course require
massive investments and reforms
we are mobilizing up to 300 billion
euros
approximately 75 billion euros will go
in grants will be in grants and
approximately
225 billion in loans
this will include some financing around
about 10 billion euros in missing links
for gas and lng
so that no member state is left in the
cold
and up to 2 billion for oil
infrastructure
in view of stopping the shipment of
russian oil
all the rest of the financing that's 95
of the overall financing
will go into speeding up and scaling up
the clean energy transition
now we need to do the same on defense
and that was the second package of today
we all know that the return of warfare
to europe has underlined the effects of
years of defense underspending
we have basically lost a decade in
defense investment because of all these
cuts
however and that's good news member
states are now reversing this trend
they have announced an additional 200
billion euros in defense spending over
the next few years
now we must keep the momentum
but more important is not only the money
that will be invested but how it will be
invested
and therefore we must make sure that the
money is spent in a coordinated way
that it addresses the capability gaps we
obviously have that europe has
identified be it in the european union
or in nato
and that the way of spending strengthens
our european defense industrial bases in
the long run term
so we ask
for joint procurement because joint
procurement is better
operationally for our armed forces
because it strengthens the
interoperability between the armed
forces
it's better financially because of the
economy of scale
and it's better industrially because it
strengthens our industrial basis here in
the european union
and it strengthens our vast network of
innovative smes
for that we will
set up immediately a task force with
member states
to coordinate the immense
needs of procurement and replenishment
right away
this task force will be accompanied by a
financial incentive instrument to
purchase jointly the experience is if
you have if you nudge the member states
by a financial incentive instrument it's
easier really to go forward together
and finally in fall we will propose a
regulation to make sure
that joint procurement benefits
from full vat
exemption this will strengthen our
independence and resilience and at the
same time it will strengthen nato too
finally my third and last topic
i want to come back to russia's war on
ukraine
this war is the driver of this
acceleration in our efforts to
strengthen
europe's resilience
we know that ukraine is on the front
line and defending our european values
we will continue to be by their side
throughout this war
and when they will rebuild their country
and this is the third issue i wanted to
inform you about today
we are proposing for ukraine
to top up the significant short-term
relief provided until now
with a new exceptional
macro financial ex
assistance to ukraine
of up to 9 billion euros in 2022
this is for the short term for the
relief right now to support the
government budget support
but of course we need to think about the
day after and the wider reconstruction
efforts
and here the european union has a
responsibility and the european union
has a strategic interest
in leading this reconstruction effort
as you know the eu leaders invited us to
reflect on this at their meeting in
versailles and that's what we did
and today we come with
principles how to build such a facility
or such a platform
the reconstruction principles should
combine investment and immediately
reforms
in time
these combination of investment and
reform will support ukraine in pursuing
its european path so it's very important
for the accession process
it should be a future-proof plan
fully reflecting the needs identified by
ukraine
the plan would tackle key reforms in
areas such as anti-corruption
administrative capacity the rule of law
the independence of the judiciary you
name it
and of course it should be firmly
anchored in the green and digital
transitions and the fundamental european
values
but of course the european union would
and should not be the only one
contributing to this effort
and this is why we are
proposing a reconstruction platform as
part of this plan
so platform jointly led by ukraine and
the european commission
and bringing thus together the member
states with a contribution bilateral
donors international donors
the international financial institutions
and other like-minded partners
the aim of this platform would be
to agree on the direction of travel
and to ensure maximum synergies of all
efforts
these investments will help ukraine to
emerge stronger and more resilient
from the devastation caused by putin's
army
so today
is another milestone on our way to more
europe
this is about seizing the moment
and this is our moment thank you very
much
you